[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
and your money phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five sherry's gonna start
off this hour in boston hi sherry
welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
um i am a retired teacher my husband
will be retiring in four years he's a
teacher also
we owe 45 000 on our house
which would be paid off by the time he
retires
my question is next june will just sell
thirty thousand dollars on the mortgage
should i take thirty thousand dollars
from my ira
and pay the taxes on that and then use
the 30 000 to pay the balance of the
house
and then use the payments that we would
have had from the mortgage
to put into my roth ira
what is your household income
um with my pension of 59 000 my husband
makes 83 000. so we have 147 000.
wow okay good and how much is in your
ira
my ira has 107 000.
why with that huge income can you not
just pay off the house out of your
budget this year
um we
we are cash flowing our daughter's
college with anthony's help she's got
many scholarships and has them but
um we she is just a freshman in that and
we are paying off
cash flowing that how much is that a big
amount
33 000 a year that we're cash flowing
wow but you said you make 140 right
right
yes now do you have any other debt
sherry
no we we do not good for you yeah well
you're doing great
um i i if it were me i would not use the
ira to do this
i would use some of your fabulous income
yeah your cash flowing 33 000 but you've
got you've still got income
room uh maybe we don't do it in one year
maybe we do it in two years but two
years but let's pay 20 000
a year for two years and be debt-free
that's what i would do yeah yeah
i agree with him sherry as well i would
take that up to 2-5
just being right on the math at 45 000.
uh but yeah
i would not touch my ira i would save
that for retirement and just get
aggressive with it
i'd rather you be aggressive over the
next two years so you can enjoy the rest
of it
then to be comfortable the next five to
six years um
that's just in my opinion yeah that's a
good move yeah good move all right
nathan is with us nathan is
well i can push the wrong button nathan
is
in grand rapids hi nathan how are you
great dave hi anthony thank you guys for
taking my call
sure i'm a 22 year old master student
and i currently have about thirty
thousand dollars
from my undergraduate degree okay you're
fine what your phone came out you have
how much in student loan debt
about thirty thousand thirty thousand
dollars all right yes
um i was very fortunate that i received
a trust fund from my um from my
grandparents when i was in high school
that i'll soon be able to access um at
the time it was worth about 33 000
and it has since grown to about 58 000
okay my question is whether i should use
the money in that trust fund to
immediately pay off
all of my student loan debt or if i
should
work and pay that student loan debt out
of
future wages and then have that trust
fund continue to accumulate and use that
as a down payment on a house
when do you graduate uh hopefully as
long as things go well
uh this coming spring so spring of 2022.
how are you paying for the following
this coming year
um so i received a graduate
assistantship which covers all of the
funds for all the costs for college and
then i get a small stipend as well
so i don't have to pay for my my
graduate degree and what are you living
on
i'm living mostly on that graduate
stipend which is about 12 000 a year
right now
and then i have a couple side gigs as
well okay so you're not
um going into further debt
correct that's good okay i'd pay off
student loan
debt today then absolutely now do you
have any other debt though nathan
any credit card from student loans okay
so no credit cards no no car notes
no absolutely i'll go ahead and cut that
check today
yeah i'll just be debt-free and then
that that still leaves you
with um 20 some thousand dollars laying
around in that trust fund that you can
use to start your life with after
graduation yeah
uh you use some of that for your
emergency fund and maybe some of that
for about
maybe some of what's left over above
that for your down payment on your first
house absolutely no rush on the house
you're doing great
now dave let me ask you a question i'm
pretty sure america is thinking well why
not dave
let let the other 20 000 sit in the
trust and let it grow it could
from now until graduation but at that
point i would move it to
an emergency fund and to a down payment
fund yes sir and uh so it's invested is
what it amounts to you can leave it
there
yeah but i pay off student loan today
absolutely out of it and be
just be clear and and make sure then
that you have a plan
for no additional debt yes and it sounds
like you got a plan for that sounds like
you gotta you know we
question you through that we walk
through it so it sounds like you've got
a
a way to pull that off and just make
sure you stick to that plan
yeah whatever it takes in america the
reason why dave acts
hey how you can get through the rest
because then we would have said hey
take that money and cash flow the rest
of your college experience yeah
then when you graduate take the rest of
it and pay off your student loans
and then go into baby steps three and
three b because goal number one
is no more debt yes you can't there's no
sense in with the left hand paying off
debt and with the right hand going back
in it right
that that's just you're just dog chasing
his tail at that point it's not you're
not making any progress
yeah so it's exactly right yeah that's
the plan
and anthony he he's done a really really
smart thing there he's
become an employee yes in a sense of the
of the school and that sets him up to be
a
uh doing graduate work for free for free
and when you look at it i mean i talk
about this in my book dave is
figure out how can you work for the
school to get a paycheck
um or to get your tuition reduced or
free you know and sometimes some schools
dave now are doing we'll give you a a
small paycheck
like he said 12 000 a year and your
tuition for free
that's a great program to go into but
here's the thing dave people are not
stepping back and doing their research
to see what's out there and by the way
all the jobs
at colleges that are universities that
you can do
that would allow you to go there
debt-free because you're an employee
don't have to be glamorous right you can
be the janitor
yes sir yes you can be the janitor and
for four years
absolutely and go to school for free and
sweep floors
or bus tables or whatever yeah i mean
you can be the
the you know the guy working out there
driving the lawn tractor right
doesn't matter with a weed eater doesn't
i don't care what you're doing
um and so it doesn't have to be like you
you got some kind of a
white collar high-tech job or something
at the university
i just want you to be on their payroll
so you get the employee benefit of
free tuition that's it doesn't have to
look good
that's part of the debt-free degree plan
yeah my philosophy is it doesn't have to
look good to be good
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i'm dave ramsey this is the ramsey show
we're glad you're with us the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
825-5225
david is with us david is in dallas
how are you david good how are you doing
today
better than i deserve what's up yeah
quick question uh my wife and i have
been debt-free except for our house for
the last few months
um we have our savings plan saved up
we've started
we've gotten back into retirement
savings and started saving for our kids
college
uh we have three kids our oldest is 14
but
and we had we didn't have much save for
really anything until the last few
months where we started um
really focusing on college so should we
continue
to do that and hold off paying the house
or paying extra on the mortgage while we
try to catch up college-wise or should
we still do four five and six at the
same time
uh you can do them at the same time but
you're probably going to have to focus
on college out of that
in order to make it because you're
getting a late start you just got a few
years and you're going to have to
be real heavy on baby step five and real
light on baby step six or you can do
nothing on baby step six until you get
through the college thing
that's okay right yeah what are you
thinking for college are we looking at
in-state
yeah definitely okay um so
obviously yeah your phone's cutting out
i can't we're having trouble hearing you
try again
oh i'm sorry can you hear me now yes
okay
um yes definitely thinking in state uh
we're in texas with lots of options but
yeah yeah i kept going back and forth on
whether doing a little bit on six or
just focusing entirely on five
and with your advice i'm thinking it's
probably best to just focus on five for
you know the next few years at least
yeah i think you get the college thing
behind you because it's right at your
doorstep yeah yeah
otherwise you're going to end up fight
you're going to end up with a mortgage
and still be trying to cash flow some
college yeah
yeah yeah you got four years what's your
household income real quick david
uh my wife and i combined are about 165.
yeah that's good because the average
in-state school in texas is gonna be
right around ten to eleven thousand
dollars so
i think over the next four years just
really buckle down
get about 40 grand in there you should
be straight you know for in-state school
yeah and start training the kids that
that's their option yes because you're
not you're not going to send them to a
60 000
year school absolutely you're not going
to have the ability to
and so let me send you a copy of
anthony's book debt debt-free degree
yeah you can thumb through that and it
also kind of gives you a a good
uh conversational jumping off point with
the kiddos absolutely go guys this is
what we're doing that's our plan
you're gonna be working while you're in
school so you pay for part of it
you're going to be working right now to
make sure your grades are stellar and
you get
trained up for your act tests so you can
get the
points there you get and you know
qualify for more scholarships
you're going to do your part and part of
your part is go ahead and just set your
expectations you're going inside the
state of texas
yes yeah you know what dave one of my
friends told me something
you just said set their expectations
unhappiness comes from
um expectations not met so if you start
setting the kids
expectations at at this level yeah
you're going to end state
they're going to be happy because you've
already set the right expectation yeah
exactly unmet expectations yes you know
lowered expectations are the secret to
happiness
this is my golf game right here so
i'm happy just because i don't expect
much that's right that's true
you know i had to deep dive into that i
was like that's pretty good i like that
okay all right i love it ray is with us
ray
is uh in louisville kentucky hi ray how
are you
hello dave it's a real pleasure to speak
to you you too how can we help
well in late 2019 my income
roughly tripled a good problem to have
and in 2020 i got real aggressive with
paying off debt
i was able to clear off a motorcycle
debt
all credit cards and the last two items
are now a house
uh and a car but one of the things i
also did over 2020 is i bought bitcoin
and it's ballooned into this
huge account now worth roughly a hundred
thousand dollars
so one of the things i want to do with
it is obviously pay off the car but it's
not quite enough
to pay off the house so i guess my
question is
do i wait with this volatile asset or do
i sell it all and move it into something
more traditional
because over the course of 2020 i
actually did the figures and it's earned
me 649 percent
and the expectations are uh that it
could go even higher now it's a volatile
asset
it swings now every day
uh you know it was worth
the swings now are more than it was
worth a year ago
so i guess i'm just kind of nervous
about keeping this large
amount of cash in this volatile asset
and but still having to worry about a
house that i'd like to pay off
in the meantime yeah you're
you got vegas problems man i mean you
walked up to the slot machine put a
quarter in and it dumped a bunch of
quarters out and now you want to keep
you have this temptation to think that's
a plan yeah um
and and so and thus is the problem with
anything that is a
extremely uh volatile
uh asset to use your phrase and also
uh uh you know unpredictable which is
the volatility so
um you're asking me what i would do
i would cash it all out tomorrow i
wouldn't have been in it in the first
place though so
well i was you know i'm single i felt
like i could afford to take the risk
um i had a snowball plan for all the
other items
yeah and the next two you know the next
two guys told me when he was playing the
roulette wheel too
yeah yeah yeah so i mean you know i i
can afford to lose the money and i call
this entertainment
um and he lost you know i stood there
and watched him lose 10 grand and
at the blackjack table so um you know
you can do whatever you want to do
but you're asking me what i would do i
wouldn't have been in it in the first
place
and i wouldn't stay in it and i would
cash it out tomorrow and i would put the
money on
some common sense things yes instead of
playing
instead you know you're sitting here
explaining to me all the problems
with the investment yeah yeah and
you know you already know what you need
to do yeah you just want somebody else
to say it out loud and he's trying to
justify
with his age like i'm young i have time
to lose money i don't care man i'm young
i do not have time to lose money to lose
money
does that mean i can get over my stupid
later right you know
i'm in debt i have a car that i probably
well
i want to say that you probably can
afford the car but you couldn't afford
the car
because you financed it but anyways what
i'm saying now is
i agree with dave yeah be young be wise
cash it out pay off the car um and
take your fabulous income and use that
to build wealth with that is a much more
proven strategy to build wealth
than playing volatile assets yeah you
know buying gold or buying
commodities or buying bitcoin or buying
currencies
i mean there's a lot of volatile you can
do options i mean you could be
you can be playing you know you can be
selling short on the market you can be
day trading there's all kinds of things
you can do right and occasionally make
money at it and most of the time end up
losing it all
right and uh bitcoin is in that category
i mean it's a a
high risk play and i don't know if the
numbers have changed dave but
it was isn't it right around nearly 80
percent of people lose money
on day trading on day trade yeah yeah
bitcoin but you know yeah
the bitcoins had a fabulous run yeah in
the last year but that doesn't mean it's
a
an investment you need to do right i
mean gold had a fabulous run for
for a while there but that means
investment you need to do right
these commodity plays or and currency
plays are just dangerous
and so you do what you want to do right
but i i have zero money invested in that
type of thing
i work too hard for it and i really
don't have any desire to lose it
the government takes enough of it
without me losing it and
you know that that it's a but again you
you know you're looking at the rate of
return and you're measuring that against
your risk
and you're gonna make that call yeah uh
and
but you asked us what we would do and
that's what you'll get here is we're an
expert on our opinion
here at ramsey solutions we want to
transform so many lives that disruption
spreads like
wildfire across our country imagine a
world where it's weird to have a student
loan
where people pay cash for their cars
where the credit card has become
the cigarette of the financial world
imagine getting a job you love because
you've been listening to ken coleman
imagine being part of an organization
that causes
that level of disruption with the work
you do every day
at ramsey solutions that's why we have a
thousand people at our company working
together to create
digital products if you want to join us
on that crusade we're on the hunt for
software engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front end
technologies
if you're a ux designer seo content
marketing specialist product specialist
we'd love to talk with you we're going
to hire about 300 folks this year
find out about all the available jobs by
texting
work that matters to 33 789 work that
matters to 33789
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage eric and
alicia are with us welcome guys all
right how are you
we're awesome today we're blessed good
to have you where do you guys live
ocala florida oh cool and welcome to
nashville how much
that have you paid off about 379
thousand dollars
oh how long did this take just over
eight years
wow very good and your range of income
during that time we started at only 36
000. we ended up around 150 so among
that range wow what do y'all do for a
living well right now we're in real
estate i'm in real estate
um and alicia is a work at home mom very
cool
very cool so i'm guessing with that
amount of money that length of time you
paid off your house we haven't paid for
a
house
i am looking at weird people that's
right
i love it well done what's this house
worth
about 300 000 very cool very cool you
have a paid-for house yeah
absolutely you haven't paid for hell
yeah that's so cool yeah
that is so cool well tell us the story
what happened i love your t-shirts by
the way
turtle always wins always wins in the
it paid show oh a paid for shell all
right i got it
okay i get it now all right very neat
so um when 2012 we had a financial
crisis
and i was a teacher at the time and um
you know we had a low income and i
always had the conviction that lisa
would work from home
and and have our kids at home and um
we had uh alicia had a miscarriage twice
so we had all the expenses of a baby
twice with no baby
and so we had medical bills piling up we
had credit card debt we had car debt we
had a mortgage
i mean just everything you can think of
and i was actually taking a class from a
co-worker and she kept saying dave
ramsey this and dave ramsey that i think
who the heck is this dave ramsey guy and
and uh what's his problem
and so i went up to her i said is there
a book i need to get or something she
said you've got to get the total money
makeover so i drove straight to the
christian bookstore
i bought the total money makeover and it
was like somebody throwing me a life
preserver while i was drowning
wow it was it was uh life-changing for
sure
absolutely and then alicia read it yeah
so i'm i'm not i'll be honest i'll give
me a novel you know i'll read that yeah
then i you know
i look to your book and i'll be honest i
was like not sure if i want to read this
so i but i i started and and i loved it
you know i loved and i tell
every person that because we we give
these books out like candy to whoever we
can
and um so whenever i tell people you
know they look at the cover and they're
like oh you know i'm not really want to
read this kind of book but what got me
are the testimonies
i love just seeing that was my favorite
part just seeing the testimonies of
people
that were there and that's why today is
such a big day for us and exciting
because
i was waiting for this day when i can be
a part of those testimonies
and be on the other side and say we're
here we did it and you can do it too
wow you often ask who your biggest
cheerleaders are and alicia says all the
time
you guys were we didn't have a lot of
people you know that that that dog look
you know
the dog looking confused german shepherd
we get that look a lot you know because
we're battling up against the culture
and it's no small thing but you guys
have been such an encouragement to us
the podcasts
um the books uh the youtube show there's
actually a picture
in the pictures that we sent because we
uh we flipped houses and in this journey
and um every time we flip a house it
helped us move forward and one of those
i mean we were on the third house
we're packing boxes and i'm like we're
doing this again
oh no and so i was like uh
i needed some kind of encouragement
because i was tired so on the tv we put
on
the youtube show and that that's the
picture right there and look what it
says up there
it says uh being
free is worth the sacrifice and that was
a moment i mean i was packing
wow that that podcast that just having
you on
got me through that time wow because i
was like we can do this and it's going
to be worth it
you know if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else
god's been so faithful house and
everything yes and another thing that
was really encouraging was wait
this was back at podcast we learned we
listened way um
a while ago as you talked about you sat
down with a millionaire and asked him
for a
book and reference and he said you gave
him the tortoise and the hair he gave
you the
tortoise in the hair book and um and
that has really been
our mantra and and just kind of what's
got us through because it is against
zelda intensity when you think gazelle
you think fast
right but it's not always fast sometimes
you got to just
you know the turtle and you're still
going we're still going to do this and
not give up
because you see all these other people
and all you know everything going on
around you and people want you to spend
and people want you to
you know do do live live like everyone
else but um
it was just the turtle we always kept
that the turtle always wins
we're gonna get there and um and and god
was faithful and he brings those
well you say like those um movable
sidewalks yeah it's like that focused
intensity that gazelle intensity that
you talk about so much it's like i love
that analogy if you start moving in the
right direction
it's like god puts that moving sidewalk
under you and somehow you get there
faster
you know and there's power in those
principles i mean do not become do not
be weary and doing good
because in due time you will reap a
harvest if you don't give up
and um and so that's that's kind of our
mantra it's it's a marathon and not a
sprint that's why we made the shirts
because
you know you got to have that big why
and you got to have big goals and
you know you just got to keep focused
and have that intensity along the way
so i'm curious though over eight years
to the people listening right now
they're like yo that's a
long time and they sound like it was
so easy but i know that it wasn't
uh i'm curious for the people listening
what was the hardest thing that you all
had to endure and how did you all get
through that
that season i i think uh a lot of it
we had an income problem you know you
often talk about you know
we had a spending problem but we also
had an income problem and i think that
was just all the hard work all the
hustle i mean we
we sold cars for a while we sold dog
treats
i got licensed to sell life insurance we
uh we gave music lessons you know and i
finally settled on real estate and
now alicia's running a a cleaning
business a new construction cleaning
business
but it's just all that hard work hustle
you know we work day and night and you
can't
you can't keep that up forever you know
at some point like you guys talk about
you got to let off the gas a little bit
you know but if you've if you've got a
big enough why and you've got those
goals ahead of you
you can force yourself to do quite a bit
and uh and we just hustled and
that was probably the hardest part is is
just the sacrifices that you make along
the way
you know not just not eating out and
those kind of things but just your time
just working
all the time and um i would have to say
that that's probably it but we had a lot
of encouragement
um i mean even my son he started a
business along the way he was six years
old and
he he was inspired by all the hustling
we were doing that he wanted to start a
business so i love it so
you know at six years old he's starting
this little business and i remember at
one point
he had only twenty dollars that he had
he brought it to us he said daddy i want
to give you this to you
as part of the get out of debt fund hey
let's get them in the shot for the
for the debt free screen what are their
names and ages noah
and he's eleven almost going to turn 12.
he wants everyone to know that
very cool mercy is seven well we are
proud of you guys congratulations
thank you how's it feel now that you're
there
yeah how do you feel how do you feel
nice being out of debt and not having
another
another bill every month
i think he's gonna make it i think so
too i love it
that's so cool well done all right it's
eric
and ashley hello happens all the time
i'm trying
i'm sorry i can't get it out alicia noah
and mercy from ocala florida they paid
off their house and everything
379 thousand dollars in eight years
making 36 to 150. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one going again we're dead free
[Applause]
this is how it's done wow
that's eight years
yes but they don't know anything nothing
nothing i mean no more those kids lives
are changed their grandkids lives are
changing their grandkids grandkids lives
were changed absolutely
and when when they got done screaming i
watched noah turn around and hug his
father
like that that just means his life and
and the little one has changed yeah
that's exactly how it works
well done you guys well done we're so
proud of you wow
excellent excellent stuff wow
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five rachel is with us in
anchorage alaska hi rachel
welcome to the ramsay show how can we
help thanks for taking my call
sure um my husband and i we work through
the baby steps we're on baby step
seven um we paid off our house um
we have a self-employed aircraft
maintenance business and our
current agreement with the building
owner is to rent it
for one more year and then purchase it a
year from now um for
250 000. um
so we've been stockpiling cash for that
so we have about 200
000 saved great to buy the building
great but in the meantime i've been
watching and i found
a residential property that i've been
watching for a number of years is
for sale and i want to buy it to live in
to buy a house on to build a house on
so i'm trying to figure out the best
value of our money
and can we do both
well you can do whatever you want to do
i guess but
should you do both or what would what i
don't borrow money you know that
and i certainly got to baby step 7 i'm
finally debt-free i'm not going back in
debt there's nothing i want that bad
yeah there's a lot of things i would
like to acquire
as an investment or to grow or to do
things with this business but if i don't
have the money i can't do them
because i don't borrow money right yeah
yeah well i guess what i'm wondering is
are buying the building for the business
is that considered
a personal investment property
yeah i mean you know because you would
say to pay cash for a personal
investment property so
i try to pay cash for everything yeah
yeah yeah so you know whatever i'm going
to do in this scenario i'm going to pay
cash for
and if my cash is limited which is
always the case
right we always have a limited amount of
cash and then my choices are limited
to that cash so let me ask you this
what's the other piece of property is a
piece of raw ground
correct how much is it 2 30
2 30. what's your household income what
do you make in a year
taxable income um i don't
our adjusted is about 80. okay
so you're gonna do one of these and
you're not going to do the other uh
anytime soon anyway um
what i was thinking of is plopping down
a little bit on on that land as an
option for a year and try to scratch
some money together but you can't do it
in a year
no and i don't know how long an option
they would consider
on that piece of land but you you've got
an option on the building that's going
to expire we know what that is
will purchasing this building for your
business will it help you expand as far
as in bringing more revenue
um we'd have to hire more employees and
we're not sure we're ready for that
oh but you're buying it you're already
in the building using it
correct yeah so really what it saves you
is what you're paying their landlord and
rent you become your own landlord right
right yes
that's a interesting one yeah i'm
i'm buying the building if it's me
because um i know what i've got there
and uh you can buy either one i'm just
thinking because
but the land when you buy it is gonna
it's not gonna create any cash
change right in your life right there's
no return on investment other than
you're gonna build on it someday
and enjoy it but there's not a
mathematical
transaction where you're going to get
money as a result of buying this land
you are going to get
money as a result of buying this
building and that's the savings on what
would have been rent right
correct yeah so that's how i'm making
that decision
but it's up to you i mean how much is
the rent on the building
2500 now 30 000 a year yeah
that's that's 35 of your household
income
i'm right there dave i'm right there
with you
i'm buying the building rachel yeah okay
yes it's because it's 30 000 a year yeah
right swing on this now i would talk to
that landowner
and i would consider renting that land
with an option to purchase it for five
years or something like that to try to
get it tied up
and meantime start piling up cash and
then pay cash for that land right
right but i mean if you could if you
could give them uh
10 15 20 000 bucks or something and uh
so much a year for for renting the thing
or something like that
uh for the option to buy it
and that option money applies to the
purchase price and say i want to i want
a five year option to buy and i'll give
you thirty thousand dollars for that or
twenty thousand dollars for that
and and tie it up and just see if
they'll do it i mean they might they may
let you do that then that put that
you get to park that and then you know
it's like a layaway plan for land right
yes
right yeah if we have the money sooner
shall we
purchase the building or should we wait
until our agreement of a year from now i
buy as soon as possible because it does
away with the 30 000
a year expense heck i mean he may not
accept it but i'll offer him 200
000 cash right now
may or may not accept it doesn't hurt to
try and see
cash do you know we can do the 250 but
it's gonna be a little while longer if
you want to close it right now we'll do
200. yeah
okay worst thing you do say no yeah
right
sometimes people need cash
and you don't know it and it's just a
powerful thing you know it's a powerful
purchasing thing yeah yeah so
wow good stuff way to go you're doing so
good rachel
baby steps this is these are great
problems to have it really is
i have no debt at all yeah land or a
building
and i have two hundred thousand dollars
saved yeah uh this is horrible i don't
know how she's getting through
i did it's great right way to go girl
i'm just so proud of you i'm devastated
this is
amazing absolutely amazing syed
is with us in kansas city hey syed how
are you
i tell you and doing good good day i
have almost
3.5 to 4 million in in the stocks right
now
and my question was as for
debt i am not debt free my how i'm still
paying for my mortgage but other than
that everything like my cars i don't
have any loan in cars and
in credit cards so i don't have any debt
other than the house
um so i did really good in stocks and
my question will be because i don't see
a
big increase in in in
stocks what i have you know made profit
in 2020 especially during this pandemic
in 201
2019 um so my question will be how can i
divide my investment
into properties in stocks in different
portfolio
and also in businesses this is what i'm
struggling for right now
yeah where'd you get this money well
done so
uh from my from stocks i work in a video
conferencing tool company
i'm an electrical engineer by profession
so i got stocks and
in this pandemic you know the stocks
really zoomed so i sold few invested in
few
other stocks and those are also doubled
or tripled well good for you i'm proud
for you good stuff
well i you know syed of course you can
do whatever you want to do oh as always
i mean you've done extremely well
congratulations
um i do not play single stocks is too
much risk
for me i've been broke and i don't want
to be there again
and so i buy very conservative
investments
and make conservative returns on them
and i'm happy with that
so i personally only do two things with
money i buy real estate that i pay cash
for
and i buy mutual funds and um
you know so uh uh and
you know it's worked out for me i've got
several hundred million dollars in real
estate
and i've got quite a bit invested in
mutual funds as well
and so um uh you know it
i i very seldom go backward it almost
always goes forward
and when you never when you hardly ever
go backward you don't have to go forward
as much
you know so that that's my plan so if i
woke up in your shoes i would say i've
had a good run
and i'm gonna uh you know use some of
this money to buy some real estate that
i pay cash for that's income producing
and
if you want to get into that world
you've got some money to do it for sure
i'm going to pay cash for the real
estate no debt pay off your house
and i'm going to start investing in
mutual funds what are you thinking i'm
right there with you dave
mutual funds and real estate i love real
estate
can't wait to get into it you've got a
pretty good year on some real estate i
have yes
well done that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey your host anthony
o'neill ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
thank you for joining us the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five austin is in
gainesville florida hi austin how are
you
hi dave i'm doing good how are you
better than i deserve what's
up uh yes i've just got a quick question
for you
about if it would make sense for me and
my fiancee to kind of swap around baby
steps four five and six
no well
and right now we're in baby step two
we're about to finish up next month
actually
um we're 25 years old we've been married
for coming up on four months now
congratulations thank you i appreciate
it
at first she wasn't too keen on the idea
of following the baby steps and
living on runners and beans but i got
her talked into it
and um like i said we're almost done
with that and then
if my math is right we should be done
with baby step three in about
five or six months by the end of the
year excellent
excellent right now
your phone's breaking up sir try again
in here now
yeah okay yes sir right now we live in a
double-wide mobile home on some family
land
uh the land is paid for we only owe
about sixty nine thousand dollars per
house
fans right now on the mobile home
yes sir oh that's a sixty thousand
dollars okay
um it was brand new when i bought it
only three years ago oh lord
um and anyways we um we know about that
much on it
and i'm just kind of curious if it would
make more sense
for us right now being that we don't
have kids um
she's in school or become a nurse
practitioner um
if it would make sense for her and i to
go ahead and kind of pay off the house
once we get
done with baby step three and kind of
hold off on investing for you know their
two and a half three years or so
um or if we should just kind of follow
them as it's written
and then stay off the house while we get
there yeah
no not austin no we
dave said in the beginning and we both
laughed but we were both very serious
uh the baby steps work for a reason man
and i get
and for me i actually want to say i like
the way you're thinking you're like hey
let's let's get 100
debt free and i love that thought
process but i also want you to think
about
if you can start investing at 26 years
old
man you're setting yourself up for
wealth down the road
now i will definitely say um i would get
an extra job
and be investing my 15 while also
going after this because that's a
depreciating
um and i could be wrong but that's a
depreciating and not as fast as the
actual brick home
so i would definitely be working very
hard to pay it off
but i'm not going to do that at the at
the sake of skipping over babysit four
and not investing at all okay
yes sir here's a problem you've got
what'd you pay for that uh
whenever i bought it three years ago the
total i financed the 74.
okay and so you've already lost fifteen
thousand dollars
yes sir and ten years from now what's
that mobile home worth
probably not very much without the land
and it's family lands
the land is worth the land is going to
be there whether the mobile homes there
or not
yeah you're not paid you're not paying
off the land you're paying off a mobile
home right
so you have 60 000 in the middle of your
kitchen table on fire burning
right yes sir so i think we're going to
do something else with this
with this trailer is what i would do
i want to get out i want to try to get
out of it as fast as i can
because it's going down not up
yes sir and that's kind of i guess kind
of where my uh questions been from
um longer like i said we live we live on
family land that's been in my family for
for a long long time and that's where we
that's where we intend on raising our
family is it dated to you
yes there it is it's in your name yes
sir
how many acres uh right now all together
we've got six
good for you um and it's kind of our
dream there's some vacant lots around us
and it's kind of our dream to be able to
you know pay cash for those lots and
build a house on that yeah um to
increase how much land we have
what is your household income right now
we're at about a hundred and three
thousand
i'm a firefighter and first okay
and uh this this was not on your radar
so it's gonna be really really hard for
you to swallow
but i'm worried about you burning sixty
thousand dollars over the next five
years or ten years
and so i would want to cut this fire
short if i were you
um and i don't know exactly how to do
this but i think i'm going to get that
trailer sold
now i might move into an apartment and
then get a construction loan and build a
house
yeah i like that dave
because i every day you keep that thing
your money's going the wrong way
right yes sir
that's that's the problem so i just i
don't i don't know what we're doing
there but
um that that's not that's not what
you're thinking because you were
thinking you're gonna ride this thing
all the way into the dirt and i i just
wouldn't burn 60 000 bucks up
yeah it's too hard to come by you've
done a great job you've made a lot of
progress
you've got a game plan by the end of the
year you're going to be in good shape
and it might be that next spring you
start trying to get this the mobile home
sold
and you may have to put some money with
it to sell it you may end up owing more
on it than it's worth
yeah and um so uh uh
i mean you you very well could be upside
down in it uh
and so i'm i'm gonna limit my losses by
getting rid of it
and that part but then you got a place
to live so i'm thinking move into an
apartment and get you a construction
loan
and build a house on the family land
because homes go up in value
the land is an independent part of this
you have a free gift of land that's
wonderful
but that you got that whether you put a
mobile home on it or whether you put a
stick built home on it that's going up
in value yeah
and so i just i um yeah it's a problem
you've got because you bought a very
expensive depreciating asset
yeah and dave i'm still new in the whole
mobile home areas
will it be more difficult to sell a
mobile home yes it's very difficult wow
it's uh because it because there's no
land under it he's not gonna sell the
land
yeah yeah okay he would just be selling
the mobile home but it's that
it's very i use mobile homes hard to
sell okay
and if you're not a mobile home dealer
you know i mean so there
it can be done yeah and obviously it's a
nice pro a nice one
yeah i mean you got a lot of money tied
up in it right but uh um
but that's the problem i've got so
anyway you
you handle it however you want sir i
think you've made really really good
progress
and i think that thing's going to be a
boat anchor around your neck while
you're trying to go swimming
as you go forward because you've got
this blessing of this fabulous piece of
land six nice acres there without any
uh and you know if you get a house built
on there and then you start saving money
like crazy
and one of those lots comes available
you can buy it and add on to your
property
and buy that with cash you know that
could be the next 10 years of your life
is just kind of building out that farm
area there
yeah so very cool it's a good it's a
good plan but i don't want to wake up 10
years from now and be living in
something that's worth nothing
while i watched it burn down
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal so dave today's question
comes from willmar in san diego
california i'm 20 years old made two
thousand dollars per month and have
eleven thousand dollars in savings
i live with my parents but some friends
and i want to get an apartment
next year i attend community college and
will transfer to a university
soon with rent being so expensive in our
area
i'm afraid i won't be able to cash flow
school when i transfer
what should i do i was rocking with you
until you said
i will not i'm not sure if i would be
able to cash flow school
when i transfer um before i was like
yeah man move out
if you can pay cash for school and an
apartment but since you cannot
uh pay cash for college um
and rent then you're going to stay home
there's no shame in the game of being at
home while you're going to school yep
none whatsoever i'll be happy and that
enables you to do that without a debt
free yeah
i mean without any debt that's just
that's uh um
that's that's job one yeah yeah and
college students dave they want they
they get excited for the experience and
they don't think about the cost of the
experience down the road
yeah and so uh man experience all you
can
at the crib yeah so see see what
what happens here is that people do a
switch in their minds okay
so he moves out and then he gets student
loans and he says i got student loans to
go to college
yeah no you didn't you got student loans
for an apartment right
because you could have gone to college
free yes or debt-free yeah while living
at home yeah so you really borrowed
money
to be in an apartment yep now we're
talking dumb
that what davey just called me dumb
because i did that
i've done dumb i've been very very vocal
about all the stupid things i've done
but that's you know that's what happens
is we're that we're financing lifestyle
very often yes sir with these things
indirectly
and so but we go oh well education is
expensive well it is expensive when you
move in an apartment with a skylight a
jacuzzi and a racquetball court
it gets expensive then you know that's
exactly what happened so um
anthony you nailed that perfectly done
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five jamie
is in
evansville hi jamie welcome to the
ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
all right so my husband and i are in
baby steps four five and six
and we are currently looking at
refinancing our home
we currently have a 30-year va loan at
four percent
we're almost eight years into that loan
um our current loan value remaining is
two hundred thousand
and our home is worth about three
hundred thousand and so as we're looking
at our refinancing options i've been
really
surprised um that our current lender has
given us all the data points we've asked
for and the va
30-year loan has actually had the lowest
rate and closing costs and i hear you
say all the time that the va loan is
generally one of the most expensive
so i'm just calling to ask what should
are there other questions or is there a
gotcha
like what should we be asking because it
seems
almost too good to be true there's just
something wrong
um in the equation because a va loan
is more expensive that the rate is
slightly higher
than a fannie mae loan and uh have you
got a credit problem
no we have excellent credit no and and
so the rate we were getting is 2.75
for a 15-year conventional or a 30-year
va loan okay so the same rate but but
the closing cost
closing costs for the va loan are 5200
and for the 15-year 8200 and then a
little over 10 000 for the 30-year
conventional
uh they include the funding fee i i
listen
you need to get a um a second
uh bid so to speak get in touch with
churchill mortgage
and have them run numbers for you and
and see and then then you can smell out
what's going on here because
uh the va loan when you come to the
closing table is just it should be
i mean it has more fees associated with
it it's in order to do the underwriting
unless somehow they're piggybacking on
your existing loan
and not having to hit a funding fee that
may be what's happening
but call churchill mortgage and talk it
through with them and see if they can
figure out what's happening here
i'm not mad about you getting a va loan
if it's the cheapest one
take it yeah but do a 15-year fixed and
take the take the 15-year fixed with the
best rate and the best closing costs
i don't i don't care if it's a va loan
in your case uh but it just
normally isn't it's just normally not as
expensive now
the only thing i can think is is somehow
you're getting some credit for some of
the va
fees from your original loan and they're
moving them over to this and you're not
you know so you're not getting charged
as much as if you'd walked in off the
street to do a va
that's possible uh and and i don't know
the nuances of that but that's the only
thing that comes to mind
because if you just walk in off the
street to get a va loan or
fha you're gonna find that much so
it's that easy hey thank you for the
call we appreciate you joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
we'll talk about your money hunter is
with us in texarkana
texas hey hunter how are you
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
hey i was calling to uh to say i
recently became
debt free um and i'm working through the
baby steps way to go
my cup thank you thank you very much um
my company offers a raw 401k
good um with a match great my question
was
my question was should i put all 15
percent into the roth 401k or should i
just do the
up to the company match and then put the
rest into a roth ira
how much is their match real quick
hunter uh
it's four percent up to four percent i
think i put in five they put in four
that's wonderful yeah well either the
non-matching portion of your roth 401k
is exactly equal to an individual roth
ira
if you're investing in exactly the same
thing
so the only reason you would do an
individual is
if you don't have good mutual fund
options
or great mutual fund options and you
could get better ones on your own
uh because the ones in your 401k are a
little weak
okay yeah that's what i i met with a
with an advisor a few weeks ago and he
was talking to me about
how he could probably build me a kind of
like an all-star portfolio whereas kind
of the
the company that my or the service that
my company uses may be limited
well that would be true because you know
you've got eight or ten options to pick
from your 401k uh and you've got 8 000
mutual funds to pick from in the open
market for your individual ira
so you should be able to find something
that will perform now what you won't
find what you shouldn't
be able to find is something that's
substantially different
if you've got good mutual funds in your
401k
and you get slightly better than good
mutual funds
uh with your individual roth ira that's
fine but it's not like you're going to
double your money or something
okay so you know but i mean some a lot
of times in a 401k you don't like that
you're not wild about your options
you're definitely going to take the
match either way and then go to the
individual and get options that i'm
jumping up and down excited about
with your advisor that that's a fine way
to do it hey
great job though hunter getting through
these baby steps man and asking the
right questions
understanding what he's doing he's doing
a great job of getting his arms around
what's happening i love it
these are the people that build wealth
yes they ask questions they understand
they think he's using good critical
thinking skills
yes he's walked his way through the
process he's gotten out of debt now he's
ready to do investing
and he's following a system hours yup
that'll make him
rich yeah yeah over time over time but
not get rich quick
not at all so dave one of the things i'm
teaching over on my show
uh the table is max out your 401k
uh once you max that out then go over to
a traditional and then
for the younger people max out to hsa
are you in line with that as well
as long as uh you're not over 15 with
the total
rights right yeah yeah yeah and you know
if you're a baby step seven you max out
everything everything okay everything in
sight because you're trying to keep the
government's hands off of it i max my
hsa i max my 401k i
do back door roths anything i can do to
keep the government's hands off of
something
right because by the time it gets back
to me from them there's not much left
it's a magic formula they have up there
that's the truth
man oh man this
is the ramsey shot
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
lee and michelle are with us hey guys
how are ya
absolutely better than we deserve
welcome to nashville where do you all
live
cartersville georgia okay a little north
of atlanta then
just a little bit well welcome all the
way up here and up here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
305 000 i believe it's 9.68
excellent excellent job how long did
this take
18 months good for you wow to the day
and your range of income during that 18
months
between 190 and 210 wow you guys are
killing it what do y'all do for a living
um i'm in the insurance business with my
brother we have an insurance agency in
cartersville
and michelle i'm a parish administrator
with a church
oh great wonderful well done you guys so
what kind of debt was the 306
whoo a little bit everything uh mortgage
we actually had two mortgages because we
are actually celebrating our two-year
anniversary today almost to the minute
with you guys and actually we're
podcasting with y'all when we decided to
do the thing but
um it's mortgage credit card some tax
debt
just a little bit of everything wow okay
so you paid off your house
yes i'm looking at weird people two
houses
two houses double weird with being
newlyweds
when we got married i had a house he had
a house
so we sold my house paid that one off
okay
and used the um profit from my house to
do
our three to six months right and then
threw it into the mortgage of his house
oh good yeah good okay yeah so we're
just cleaning up
yeah yeah yeah very good starting
starting a new marriage the way you want
to start working
amen we actually started on our
honeymoon
wow we um chat we were in chattanooga
for our honeymoon
and we stopped to get gas i was the only
one with a credit card
and we cut it up in the gas parking lot
and threw it in the trash can you're
listening to the podcast
going down the road or something pretty
much that's exactly right oh my god
he ordered the total money makeovers
while we were sitting there in the
parking lot by the time we got home
no we did a couple of days before but by
the time we got home they were sitting
in our driveway waiting for us to start
them
wow it's been a lot of fun
we had a great time great great time so
just
getting married on and being excited
about a fresh start and all that
said okay we gotta address this money
thing and then the podcast just pops up
well we no that's not true we dated with
you guys a lot
uh when we yeah instead listening to
music we would listen to podcasts on our
dates
to and from i really thought he was
weird when he looked at me and said
you want to listen to dave ramsey and
we're coming home from a date night that
is weird
i went who yeah i love david but that's
real weak
i learned to love dave even more though
actually all of you guys my
um i drive an hour to work every day an
hour two
and an hour from now which means you're
a mile from home in atlanta right
[Laughter]
yeah yeah a little too much but that's
changing next week so that's a good
thing
um but you guys really inspired me
in the afternoons to go home and find
more stuff to sell on ebay
more stuff to put on facebook
marketplace more stuff to just
get rid of so you got rid of this
so yeah yeah wow so once we got to
83 oh and 83 000 i said i need something
visual
and we did a paper chain that every
change is a thousand dollars
and it hung all the way across our
breakfast room
wow and our grandkids would come in and
see it and our kids would come in and
see it and every thousand dollars we
um paid off we cut a link and it's
a new set of kitchen cabinets or he's
going to italy
or it's doing something that we knew
that thousand dollars would help us do
so when we got to that point the last
one was freedom
and so we have kept all these little
pieces of paper
and we just start pulling them out and
what are we going to do because
you helped us get here so proud of you
so much
thank you proud of you we were just
under bondage with a chain
yeah and that was just a really good
visual for us but it was also a
witnessing tool for us
to to not only witness about what the
lord's done in our life but also witness
what
your program can do for other people i
mean we were just talking to a couple
off
off off set here just a minute ago and
and they're
they're they're in their 20s it would
have been nice for us to start in our
20s but we're in our late 50s and
you know it's never too late that's it
it's never too late
you guys are impressive very very well
done thank you
i'm excited we're i'm we're an
elp for you guys oh okay but i gotta
tell you
i always wanted to be one but i knew i
did not want to even think about it
until i got my house in order wow
and once i got our house in order then i
made application and went through the
interview process
and met some great people and wow our
agency is now an elp farm okay so on the
pnc side
on the pnc side very cool yeah well i'm
honored to have you as part of the team
man that's incredible thanks thank you
well done well done how does it feel to
have not a payment
in the world oh my it's
like um nothing i've ever felt before
truly i mean i love being married to
this man because he is my leader
and he is the head of our household and
he got me into this craziness
but i don't know of any other way that i
will want to live the rest of my life
yeah so thank you so much we spent our
anniversary in nashville and i told her
i said baby
the best part about it everything we've
done while none of it was extravagant i
said there's no bills waiting for us
when we get home
right and there's no money that we've
got to send to anybody else other than
just our normal power bill and things
like that
i love it vacation not gonna follow you
home
sounds like your life is a vacation
though much much so
it is we each day is
um a breath of fresh air yeah it really
is yeah to not have that load
waiting on you when you put your feet on
the floor and know that you're having to
go to work
to pay that load off yeah is amazing so
or if the air conditioner bust on the
way home
no big deal yeah so you had 18
very intentional very intense months
what was the toughest part of that
you know it really wasn't that tough
and i know i don't mean to say that i
mean it was tough it was a lot of hard
work
you didn't do a lot of things but we did
not do a lot of things and
and we got a lot of people say well come
on you can just do that little bit or go
buy yourself a new set of golf clubs or
go do this or go
do that and i'm like nope we've got
other plans for that
that money's going somewhere else and i
said i can do that later yeah or she
would do the same thing
the envelopes they were my best friends
and i would be at lunch with a
girlfriend or we'd go
shopping and i'd pull out an envelope
i'd go
nope it's gonna have to wait i can't get
those shoes or she'd say where do you
want to go to lunch well let me look
and i'd look and go well i got seven
bucks in my meal envelope so
let's figure out where we're going to
eat you know so
and he handed me this i looked over
there earlier and i said
i love the new um wallets and i said but
i wouldn't give mine i wish i had it
it looks like it's just falling apart
yes it is it's just falling apart and
envelopes i'd get to the point that i
didn't have any extra envelopes
and i'd write all around them you need
to put that in the chain link
zip bag yeah and keep it all as a memory
for the grand babies
absolutely and then go get you a nice
envelope system that says racial cruise
on a minute ago
she said i really like the new ones over
there yeah yeah
you've earned it you've enveloped like
no one else now you can envelope like no
one else
yeah all right it's liam michelle from
the atlanta georgia area
306 000 paid off in
18 months making 190 to 210.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
wow that's some happy newlyweds
absolutely
look at it i love it that is so
fun that is so fun well done what rock
stars man
so you're out there at the gas pump
and you're listening did you hear what
she said she caught up her credit cards
at the gas pump at the gas
i made the decision never again and
brothers here and you're listening right
now and you're going
well yeah well what about you when are
you gonna do it if you're listening to
us right now what's your problem
when are you gonna do it it's there for
the taking baby
you just gotta decide you can do it they
can do it
it's possible this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
when it comes to making big money or
life moves
like buying a home or getting married
having a baby it's likely the last thing
on your
mind to make sure you have the right
insurance coverage
but it should be on your mind big
changes are overwhelming
what would it what would be even more
overwhelming to find yourself in a
situation where you didn't have the
right coverage
because you forgot about the insurance
part of this
big event if not having the time and
energy is what's keeping you from
getting the right insurance coverage
use one of our endorsed local providers
like the guy that just did his debt free
scream
uh they're independent insurance agents
who will shop among a gazillion
companies free
and get you the best price
and they do all the work they work for
you
all you've got to do is text insurance
to 33789
text insurance to 33 789
to get connected with an elp and let a
pro help you find the coverage
that fits your life insurance text
insurance to 33789
this is the ramsey show anthony o'neil
ramsey personality is my co-host
today liza's with us in orlando florida
hi liza
welcome to the dave ramsey arthur the
ramsay show what's up
hi thank you for taking my call and i
appreciate what all you guys do i've
been starting to listen now since we've
had to stay
home so it's been a little education
here but
i still have a couple of questions and
um
my house has paid off and i have a
friend who told me
why are you paying the insurance i mean
when have you had
something catastrophic happen since you
bought the home well once
when um hurricane irma came and i was
going to put the roof on myself but irma
helped me along so the insurance paid
for it
so she says you got a full roof on now
what else can happen the fire station's
about two
two blocks from you um or either lower
the replacement value
and i'm just a little bit scared about
not having insurance on the house
because this is my only asset you know
that i have that
big-time money so i think your friend's
kind of dumb
right and she has money to back up if
she had any problem with the house i
i i'm not that right i've got the money
to write a check and rebuild my house
but i have homeowners insurance
okay so i should just continue that
because i don't even know if i can
not have insurance on the house um
should i lower the replacement value or
should i leave it the way
you know if you're going to pay for
insurance pay for insurance that
replaces the house if it burns
okay well the fire station's two blocks
away i know
but you still have something will still
burn i mean it can still
i mean i don't you the chance you're
having a total loss is
not there probably depending on what
happens
but um i mean i've been to orlando i was
there last week
there you guys have thunderstorms like
we have in tennessee
yes so who's to say you don't get struck
by lightning i don't know that's true
yeah because we're the capital for light
or lightning strikes
yeah but i wouldn't think i would have
been able to do it because i have an
equity line on the house
no they're not going to let you i
thought you said you had it paid off
well the house has paid off
no it's not you've got an equity line a
different company it's with my bank with
my checking i know but it's
they've got it your house is not paid
off they have a lien on your house yeah
oh so and i've been just letting that
linger there because i just thought it's
like like an open credit card type of
thing my husband's passed away so now
i'm dealing things on my own
he's probably rolling on his grave
listening to my conversation now
oh yeah no listen you're doing good
because you're asking questions and
you're learning that's always good
let's leave the insurance in place and
let's call the bank and cancel the
equity line
okay i don't because i don't have
anything hardly on it's probably about
500
or something yeah but the value of it is
like 30 so
yeah that's the looking for a place to
happen is what it is yeah
let's get rid of it absolutely yeah i
there are times that you can self-insure
through some things that you want to um
but not a house though right not a house
i i just
you know but i mean you know like i had
a a three thousand dollar jeep
yeah that was at the lake house right it
was just a lake house jeep yep
and um i did not carry collision on it
yeah
because they wanted like five hundred
dollars
for collision on a three thousand rg but
i'm like i'll just take the you know
i'll take the risk it's a three thousand
dollar jeep i can
if i if the thing just explodes tomorrow
into a thousand pieces because
you know whatever i hit a wall with it i
don't know then then
i'll just get another one it's not
because it's not a big deal but yeah
stu you know my nicer cars i still carry
coverage on
now because i've looked at it i'm going
okay i've got this vehicle that's worth
this
yeah uh i can afford to buy one of those
a month
right right even though it's expensive
but i'm in a financial condition to do
that
right but i look at the value that i'm
covering versus what it costs me to
cover it
and i'll let them take the risk for that
ah it's just a value proposition for me
and so but you know technically
they're making money on me and and
technically it would cost you more money
if you didn't have it insured i mean you
have to go
drop you know the money when technically
if you pay the insurance you come out
cheaper if something was to happen well
certainly something happens but that's
when they don't come out
right and on average you know they're
going to come out absolutely
that's the deal yeah but uh but i still
carry coverage on the cars
the nicer cars yeah and on other things
uh and of course i carry liability on
everything lots and lots of liability
it's the best
buy in the insurance world and dave is
saying he covers he he carries
full coverage on the nicer cars yeah
make sure america hears that yeah
but i don't you know but but you know if
i've got a farm truck or something
i don't i don't put a bunch of insurance
on it you know it's not what we're doing
it's it's a
that's an easy enough thing to replace
and you have full coverage on your lake
house even though it's not it's not as
big as your
house but it's you have full coverage on
your lake house absolutely yeah
that's gonna make sure people understand
that and they're all paid for and i
could
write a check and build one of those in
30 seconds if something happened to one
of them but i'm gonna
go ahead and let the let the homeowner
sit in place
it's just pretty simple and uh starts to
add up after a while but
it's a it's a good goodbye yeah so good
question liza
crystal is in harrisburg pennsylvania hi
crystal welcome to the ramsey
hi hi guys hi good to talk to you guys
you too
um i started listening to you guys
probably about a month ago
and i am the gazelle and my husband
is not so we have two car loans i think
one is seven hundred dollars and one is
eight thousand our house has been paid
off for years
and he i'm ready to take the money out
of the savings and just pay them off
but he's like you just you just don't
take your capital you just don't take
your capital so
you've already taken it when you bought
the car
you took it when you pay it off you just
admit it
i i did all the numbers i said look how
much interest we're saving and this and
that
and it's just i just can't he has agreed
that
this month we're going to pay off his
vehicle
and then we're going to double the
payments on my car
so but i always do that you're taking
you you're
using up the capital yeah
well we're taking his car payment i know
it's not logical
yeah i do you all have the money in the
savings crystal to go ahead and yeah she
got the money to pay it all off today
yeah yeah how much do you have in
savings
uh 19 000. okay
honey i mean we're set like it's like
i'm all over the place with the baby
steps i mean our
our retirement is is really good and
you know i want to do the six months
after
you know trying to push that and
everything but we have no other bills
and yeah yeah i'm paying off both of the
cars i don't know how to get him to do
it but i would write a check today if i
were in your situation and pay off
everything i'd be debt free
um uh but you know the capital's gone
you've already
spent the money when you bought the car
when you pay off the loan is when you
just admit what you've already done and
maybe that line of reasoning will help
him get his head around that
but um i mean if you use his principle
when you get the car paid off you would
turn
around and borrow on it again so that
you had capital yeah
but borrowed money does not represent
capital
that's not a proper term that's not
proper terminology
you know and a simple savings account is
not using your capital so
now you need to yeah i don't know how to
talk him into it but i i
i think you just continue the
conversation tell him what it'll mean to
you how you how you wanna
how it's gonna make you feel a lot
better big gift to you for him to do
that
and maybe that'll help i don't know
good luck with that that puts this hour
of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality number one
best-selling author
and host of the table big time
youtube and podcast explosion that's
happening
is my co-host today uh you jump in we'll
talk about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five five tiffany is with us in
sacramento
hi tiffany how can we help hi dave
um i have a little complicated issue
here hopefully i can explain it
okay my husband had a job change and
real estate is different in various
parts of california
and we had to leave our home we're
renting it out we only
owe three and a half years on it now
so we because my husband's job changed
so we left that house
but are renting it out we owe three and
a half years
but where we live now real estate is
super expensive and so my husband wants
to sell the house
i have sentimental value to the house if
we
if he lost his job we would go back to
that house
if something happened to him i would go
back to the house so i feel like it's
more
advantage to have a paid off house and
oh
the only way we could buy a house in the
area that we live
would have to be a 30-year loan uh
so it makes me sad to think about
selling that house
and you know walking away with maybe two
hundred thousand dollars
and still having a 30-year loan am i
making sense at all
um well i mean i understand what you're
saying if that's what you mean
the uh where is the house
uh the house that we only owe three and
a half years on yes ma'am that's the
only one you've got
right yes it is in uh susanville
california
you've probably never heard of that no i
haven't how far how far away from you is
it
four hours okay all right
and you left there because he took a job
in sacramento
yes do you feel like his job in
sacramento is going to end
soon no
so how long do you think you'll be in
sacramento
um you know we have children that are
in college now or getting college age so
i really don't know i mean that's kind
of part of my reason too it's like do i
really want to buy a house but then we
try and rent a house i mean are you
alright
i mean are you going to be there two
years are you going to be there 20 years
yeah
yeah yeah yeah two years 20 years
maybe not 20 years yeah how old are you
guys
i'm 46 my husband's 10 years older okay
all right so he's going to work 10 more
he's probably going to work 10 more
years anyway right
right yeah he suggested tennessee all of
us californians are moving to tennessee
now
okay so how would that take you back to
susanville
yeah right i'm not for moving to
tennessee i want to stay in california
oh okay
um
i don't think this is about the house
i think this is about you holding on to
susanville
right
why is the house sentimental
um
i don't know gotta know this just is
how long did you live there right um we
were there about nine years
was that your first home yes yes you
know i brought my girls home there
does it is it just because i hear like
security as well like if
something happens i kind of almost feel
like you're like you're grieving
the fact that you left there
yeah there's a lot of different greens
so
anyways yeah it's i just part of me
is yeah i'm attached to the house yeah
part of me
it makes me sad to think that i probably
wouldn't have a paid off house until i'm
close to 80. that green well i don't i
don't think that's true what's your
household income
um probably 180 190
okay so close to 200. yeah i mean i i
think you guys need to do some more
investigation of real estate in your
area
um i mean sacramento is a more expensive
market than susanville for sure
but it's not san diego and it's not it's
not san jose it's not silicon valley so
i think making 200 000 a year with a 200
000 down payment you can do a 15 year
on something that you can find in the
area and get it paid off
and and have a game plan to have paid
for house i'm not signing you up for a
30-year mortgage
i agree with you on that but i think
you're overstating that
and adding some drama to this discussion
because your heart is breaking about
susanville somehow or another
i don't know what it is i can't tell but
i mean you got
um you're not going back there
you know that logically but there's
something emotionally that says i can't
let go and i don't know what that is
so um you know i think that it's
important for you
and your husband and your all's
relationship to work through that part
of it
and i think when you kind of come to the
conclusion that you're not going back
there you're going to sell it
yeah that's what it's what i would do i
wouldn't suggest you own a rental
property
four hours away that's paid for yeah uh
i almost paid for um and so i'm gonna
select a property with my 200
000 income in sacramento with a 200 000
down payment
that's a 15 year fix and i think you can
do all that so
um uh you know i agree with your
husband's conclusions
what i still can't find and and i'm not
i wouldn't come down on you for this uh
but there's something going on with you
and this move that emotionally that
that's causing you to
think to to lean this direction and
that's more of a concern to me
if uh that for you guys
going forward for your relationship for
your peace of mind all that kind of
stuff
then just whether or not you own a house
uh in susanville
yes i mean you could kind of feel it in
the air i really can't
i i really can but i'm right there with
you dave
two hundred thousand dollars down
payment home 400 450 max five
three hundred thousand dollars to pay
off and then hey
uh and if something was to happen
and i hate to say this hopefully they
have proper term life insurance and they
take care of the house and she's
back to where she was you know she's
safe she's secure
yeah there's something about the past
that's
going on there i i yeah there's
something happening
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five thank you for joining us
america
so the thing to remember to
tiffany's credit and for it's a good
lesson from that call for all of us and
i
i have to stop and remember it uh not as
often because i've done this show for 30
years and it keeps me
remembering it but personal finance is
personal yes and so there are times with
money
that it's okay to do something that's
illogical
or maybe not the perfect math thing
because it's what you are doing yeah you
know
it's like you wouldn't logically spend
what we spent on a diamond
for an engagement ring or a wedding ring
right it's not logical
it doesn't it doesn't match the numbers
it's not a return on investment in terms
of mathematics
it's a personal thing it's a gift to
your betrothed
and so it's okay for it to be personal
it's okay to have feelings
about all this in other words
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
well by now you've probably seen all the
tax software ads that are out there
saying it's free to do your taxes with
these big companies but news flash
for most people it's not free because
you don't
meet the right criteria and by the time
you realize you don't meet the free
criteria
you put in too much time to start over
so
you pay up you get sucked into the
vortex
and that's money for these companies
this is what happens here's another
truth the same company has
loads of customer data and they sell it
their own privacy statements say so so
if they know you wound up owing taxes
they've got a green light
to send your information to their
business partners who will then
kindly help you get a loan
or a credit card and they pay
these companies for this information
that they
got off of you for free see the tax
software guys get a bonus
and you get more debt ding ding
so they're making a killing off their
customers is what amounts to and you
need something better you need something
cleaner
and that's why we stepped into the ring
ramsey
smart tax it gives you a way to file
your taxes without
paying more than you expected and
without having
your data sold so that you end up in
debt
and get pounded by these guys so it's
very inexpensive it's an
easy way to file 17 or 38 dollars it's a
very simple thing
pricing menu there's not a bait and
switch you're not going to get sucked in
text the word tax to 33 789 to learn
more
and you can start the process for free
text
tax to 33 7
89. paul is in atlanta hey paul
welcome to the ramsey show dave anthony
thank you for taking my call
sure i have a question and i was going
to see if you too could provide me with
some guidance
i got married just a couple months ago
and i had a home
that uh well thank you i had a home that
i had previously or just shortly before
a marriage i'd bought
well my wife has wanted me to add her to
the to the deed here
and to her as a co-owner but she doesn't
want to be added to the mortgage
and my thinking is if someone's going to
be on a deed
then they also need to be on the
mortgage and we're kind of
trying to debate this out i want to be
fair um
she's worried that if something would
happen if i i don't know
if something would happen that she would
have to leave the home and
like i said i want to be fair i just
don't know the right thing to do
okay um well to start with
being added to the deed and not being
out of the mortgage doesn't matter you
still have to pay the mortgage if you
die
well i think it's what i'm worried about
is if we were to in that case if
god forbid a divorce were to happen i
would be left holding a mortgage
and then someone would have you know an
ownership or an equity in my home no
that's not how it works
because in a divorce they divorce
whether you have uh whether your wife's
name is on the deed or not
she's got marital rights to your house
in a divorce you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to deal with the house as an
asset
in the divorce in most states in most
states
including georgia okay now there's some
states that don't
that aren't wired that way but the vast
majority of states are pretty simple in
a divorce
you're going to divide up the property
and what regardless of whose name it's
in
and i'm glad you you put me at ease on
that so you're you know so
i would have a will that takes care of
her
uh you can add her name or not add her
name to the deed
uh i would not go to the expense to
refinance
because her being on the live liability
the mortgage or not being on the
liability mortgage is pretty simple
you don't pay that mortgage whoever it
is somebody pays that mortgage
or that house goes away they're going to
foreclose on it dude we got to walk away
well on a financial end of i have enough
assets to where i could sell to pay the
home off
have a couple rental properties and then
some cash savings and i would be totally
100 debt free uh kids how long have you
been married
about three months oh
okay so you brought substantial assets
into this marriage
correct and she wants
like what is your net worth i'm
about hundred thousand oh okay all right
and what do you make around 160
what's she make around
40. okay how much is the house worth
could you say you have enough to to pay
it off
yes i have enough to pay the home off
and be i would have to sell a couple of
my rental properties but uh they're just
low-end rentals but
i could sell them and then be 100 what
do you owe on the house
uh 360. how old are you guys
um i'm 53 and she's 42.
this this definitely okay so
but paying off your house or not paying
off your house doesn't affect your
position um yeah i
i
unless you just hate unless you were
thinking of selling these rental
properties anyway if you are then it's
okay yeah use the cap
use the money from that unless let's
clear the mortgage but you've got a
great income i think you're going to be
able to clear the mortgage in a few
years anyway
that's what my i started listing you
just a few short months back
and that was what my goal is and just uh
maybe three to four years have the
mortgage completely knocked out
yeah and i and that does not make you
more vulnerable in a divorce situation
or her less protected uh i want to put
that current be fair
i mean it just doesn't it doesn't do all
that so i
i i um yeah i think you guys just
working together
and understanding the most part from a
legal perspective
what your rights are and if something
and having a will you need to get a will
in place uh
which would give her some comfort uh
that if something happens to you she's
you know she's gonna what she's gonna
inherit if you've got children from a
former marriage or anything then you're
gonna have them have some of the assets
she's gonna get this house whatever it
is
go ahead and have all that laid out in a
will and i think that might help the
relationship part of this discussion
yeah i agree i agree uh dave can i ask
you a question
young guy net worth is two million
dollars just got married
what's your stance on um
prenups would you advise that guy
to do a prenup yes net worth that high
yes okay yeah
i mean 2 million and above you start
looking at it and the reason
is not the
it's not the actual person you're
marrying okay it's their stinking family
and if you've got a prenup it shuts
everybody up wow
and because here's what happens the more
money is involved the more weird comes
out of the
cracks i got you weird just shows up
crazy just shows up yeah
and um and and it it just sets it aside
now i don't recommend a prenup
okay um or posting up either one
yeah in a in a situation like this you
got seven or thousand bucks that's
you know you should you know if you love
your money more and you love her you
shouldn't get married but
but you know if if you um
if you've got substantial assets
regardless of your age man or woman yeah
and you're coming into a marriage and
the other person does not
then yeah you need one just because it
takes all the weirdness off the table
it's a preset formula of they're going
to get this
in the event of a divorce and they're
not going anything else
and it's a locked down thing okay and
then if
you know their little stupid friends or
their stupid crazy family members or
whatever starts speaking into the
relationship
uh it it gives them there's a kind of a
rudder to the ship there's a plumb line
that you're bumping against that you go
okay
no that that's not going to work out
that it's not going to work out that way
got you so uh you know you're walking
away from that
and that person also knows they're going
to obviously leave the marriage with
what they came
in with got you which is nothing or
something depending on what
which person we're talking about here
right but and as it should be you
shouldn't have access
to that but i you know like i had one
guy one lady call and she said she was
dating a guy who had a
classic sports car and he wanted a
prenup
and i said uh don't marry this guy he
likes his car more than he likes you
you know no this isn't this guy's not
marriage material
this guy's a twerp yeah so don't marry
this guy right
but but yeah but i mean if you got two
million dollars yeah yeah yeah i think
you do need to set
some boundaries with that because it
just keeps the crazy
at arm's length gotcha
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage johnny and ashley are with us hey
guys how are you
good it's great good to have you guys
where do you all live selma tennessee
oh cool welcome to nashville and over
here to do a debt-free scream how much
you paid off
uh 49 700 way to go how long did it take
um exactly 21 months excellent and your
range of income during that time
um night we started out 19 000 and after
hearing about this program made it up to
sixty thousand a year
whoa so how'd you do that well
um we were always taught um this
verses in the bible about its uh the
rich man can't make it into the kingdom
of heaven
kind of stuff and um after starting to
listen to you we heard the other verses
that that wasn't evil and it changed our
mindset and i run my own business and so
i just went after it
wow good for you cool what kind of
business have you got
uh i run a handyman business good for
you that's a great business
oh yes always work for that always work
you live here in nashville and then
i wish i'd work at your house too
[Applause]
yeah cause i don't know if you know well
i'm not gonna bring that up but anyway
he might need some help i need some help
man so
way to go guys so how'd you get plugged
in what started this journey
well so we were probably in like the
lowest
part of our life um
i swore i wasn't going to get emotional
my dad had just passed away and about 20
weeks later
we had a
miscarriage at 20 weeks and
we just kind of continued to spiral down
um and he started listening to
or through somebody he heard about you
guys
and he was like you know oh they're pro
you know get out of that you probably
have to be rich or whatever
and um he started listening you know he
went
you know well we're we're as low as we
can get like how much farther can we go
i might as well look at it so he did i
was the hesitant one i mean i was
struggling real hard but um
he started showing me some of this stuff
and everything
and i don't know it just it gave me hope
seeing other people do debt-free screams
and
um so yeah anyways kind of went from
there yeah wow it's a tough year yeah
yeah i'm sorry
but uh the good news is is that um but
you know
it's almost like you can one way to work
through the grief is not to ignore it
but
uh but also to have something to aim at
yeah and you know
have a goal in front of you and that
that helps you with that process so
that's cool
and uh and then you go getting gear and
make
more money you're made in your life yeah
once we found out that it was physically
possible it gave us hope
because before we had no hope yeah so
why go to work
there's there's no reason to and then
when i saw your plan
i was like oh my god it doesn't matter
how much money you make
there's hope and so it just gave us that
drive man
you guys are impressive i'm so proud of
you yeah i took on a
a job for about um six months with a
company that i worked for
before we got married um and they took
me on
for six months and i did that and
homeschooled my girls very cool
yeah very cool well way to go you guys
so i'm curious
throughout these 21 months what was the
hardest thing because you all are making
what the average person makes in america
and and a lot of we get a lot of people
saying we can't do it it's hard it's
difficult we don't make enough money
we'll make a lot of money
but you all paid off 50 000 in less than
24 i mean less than two years so what
was the hardest thing
and what helped you push through that
the hardest part for me was not going to
the beach
and when people would ask us to go on
things
you know going out to dinner with them
or you know
just out somewhere to like you know the
movies or
you know something else and just having
to tell those people no
and they're like why and then trying to
explain why and they're like
you know it didn't make sense to them
you know a lot of people
our age that we grew up with were kind
of like you guys are crazy
yeah you know yeah honestly it wasn't
that hard because when you go from
making 19
000 a year that's below the poverty line
yeah
and then you triple that you feel like
it's not like you say when you make a
budget you feel like pay raise we had a
pay raise
and so you did so you feel like you hit
the lottery yeah our
our lifestyle increased even though we
are paying off debt increased
and um i mean because even paying half
of our income to the debt
we were still making 30 000 a year at
that rate yeah you still almost doubled
your income yeah
so so we felt like it kind of made it
hard in that sense to not
take her to the beach and stuff because
we do have more money and
before we were going to the beach once a
year um
and just using credit cards to do it
yeah wow
so that's what kind of debt this was 50
000 was credit cards and whatever it was
all credit card
um and 6 000 on a van okay wow
wow part of it was starting my business
buying tools
and um the first couple years of my
business i made 15
000 a year and then we made it to 19
000 and then when we heard about you it
just gave me that motivation to
make more i'm so proud of y'all well
done with his business
usually you know december and january
pretty hard months for us
so this past december and january
i mean we had a washer break and
everything else and
at first one thing we started having
things you know happen where you know
that was what you would use your
emergency fund for
um there was the first anxiety that
would happen you know oh my gosh and
then i'm like
wait a minute like i don't have to freak
out about this you know
anymore like we're gonna be okay we can
still pay for anything everything
you know and replace whatever we needed
to and
it didn't put us behind anywhere yeah
you guys are on your way man
so good you got all the stuff this is so
cool
so at the end of um april
we will have property and
um we're gonna build a house wow
i love it we're buying 80 acres and we
have the down payment
19 000 and 60 000 income to 80 acres
life is good well done you guys
i mean well done that is so cool can i
can i uh rent this couple acres
well we're wanting to do an airbnb and a
wedding venue um in a few years down the
road so we'll we'll send you
a free night there you go i appreciate
it there you go that's good stuff
well very cool you guys well done very
very well done and you brought the
kiddos with you
what are their names and ages um jenna
is nine
mm-hmm bella is
seven and lyra is three all right
beautiful young women very well done so
they've been practicing their debt-free
scream
yep all right let's see it i love it
very cool
all right johnny and ashley from is it
was selma
tennessee summer tennessee yeah 50 000
paid off in 21 months making 19 to 60.
well done great story you guys proud of
you
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
yay
i love it
[Applause]
wow how fun is that wow i mean dave did
you hear that from below
we were below poverty to now 80 acres
inland
yeah and no debt and no debt life is
good that's beautiful
life is good that is just beautiful just
permission
to go win yes and to give yourself
permission
to win and that's important yes sir
and um sometimes you just need somebody
to say it out loud
right you know and you got permission to
win you're allowed
it's okay oh my goodness whoa that's
powerful
well done you guys so beautiful what a
great story what a great couple yes sir
they're they're on fire man life is
good this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today deuteronomy 8 18 but
remember the lord your god
for it is he who gives you the ability
to produce wealth
and so confirms his covenant which he
swore
to your ancestors as it is today
nelson mandela said money won't create
success the freedom
to make it will that's a lot like that
young man we were just talking to yes
sir i mean that you know he just had to
have permission
to go win yeah the lord your god for it
is he
who gives you the ability to produce
wealth wow
so very interesting very interesting
and uh powerful open phones here at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five anthony o'neil is my
co-host today chris is with us in
asheville north carolina hi chris how
are you
hey dave good how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
awesome uh not too much so i've got a
last survivor adjustable life insurance
policy
that my parents put into my name three
years ago
and i wanted to get your advice on
whether i should keep it or surrender it
i'd like to give you a summary of where
i'm at with the baby steps right now
i'm 34 debt free make 52 000 a year
i'm going to be done with a six-month
emergency fund at the end of may
after that i want to save up uh to
either
build a small garage apartment or buy
something
and then i've also got uh fourteen
hundred dollars in a 401k
just sitting i'm not contributing to it
at all
are you single yes okay
all right well this life insurance
policy
was bought as an investment not as life
insurance
and it's a crummy investment has a
horrible rate of return
and the insurance portion of it is very
expensive
and so i would buy some a little bit of
term life insurance you don't need a
bunch
maybe a hundred thousand dollars or
something just to clean up your estate
if that something happened to you so
nobody had to pay to bury you or
something like that
and then i would drop this stuff oh so
this this policy is insuring my parents
not me
oh why did they put it in your name yes
i guess they wanted me to have control
of it for some reason
so it pays you upon their death
yes whoever dies last
yeah between the two of them
yes yes are you are you paying
for it or is it no it's paid up because
they paid so much into it
so they paid 46 dollars into
it from 1997 to 2013.
the current surrender value is 70 000
and the death benefit is 500 000.
oh so they're making two percent on
their money yeah um
okay so what what what happens
let's see are you morally obligated to
take care of their
uh this is just to benefit you or is
this supposed to you're supposed to take
care of their final expenses out of this
or what
have they got an estate
yes okay so you wouldn't need this if
both of them passed away to cover their
burial right
no and i assume you're the beneficiary
on the of their will as well right
i am okay yeah so basically you have
seventy thousand dollars sitting here in
an investment that's not got a great
rate of return is really what this comes
down to
are either well it's both of them it's
the last to die
are they both ill no
no they're both in good health how old
are they they're in their mid 70s their
my dad is 73 and my mom sorry my dad is
75 and my mom is 73.
uh i'm getting rid of it i'm just it's
it's basically a 70 000
investment that's sitting there doing
poorly
with that has a half million dollars
attached to it on some 75 year olds
but um yeah i'm no the
i'm going to take my 70 thousand bucks
and i'm gonna invest it well
okay and then you know that was going to
be my secondary question is
i want to have a good plan for this
money yeah
um you know if i choose to surrender the
policy so
being where i'm at you know not only
having fourteen hundred dollars in a
401k at
age 34. yeah um how would you allocate
those funds either to a down payment on
a house
or a 401k or either or
401k is payroll withheld only yeah and
so yeah
i would use a portion of it for a down
payment on a house and i would invest
the rest of it in some mutual funds
okay normally i would just put it all on
the house but because there's a lot of
weirdness in the air here about them
having done an investment for you
i'm going to try to honor that with them
a little bit and let's put some of this
into an investment so maybe twenty
thousand dollars down in the house and
50k and mutual funds or something like
that
okay because they're probably yeah and
you know they got sold this policy
by someone and they think it's a big
wonderful thing i don't
yeah i wish they had invested 46 000 for
you into something else and it'd be 146
now instead of 70. but
yeah and i i can sense some a little bit
of regret
from my dad uh you know in relation to
that okay so he's not gonna be like
his feelings aren't gonna be hurt by you
cashing this thing out then
no no they've told me that it's mine to
do with what i wish
yeah that's very healthy that's cool
yeah yeah you
didn't get a guilt trip with the policy
well you know the thing is ultimately
it's it's it's a gamble on death
and that makes me feel bad in the first
place that's yeah it's kind of weird but
yeah but
but you know but truthfully from a math
standpoint if they were both
uh in the final stages of stage four
cancer or something then you know
mathematically we'd be a little bit cold
and weird about it and hold on to it
right
yeah but we don't have that situation we
just need to take the 70
000 and do your life absolutely you do
you and
you know 20 000 bucks is a down payment
you know 50 000 into some mutual funds
and i mean are you you've seen something
else am i missing something no no
you're hitting right on it and i i like
the fat data that you said honor the
parents and go ahead and invest 50k
yeah that's one thing i was going to say
well if they did that so you can have
investments we'll go ahead and invest
but i would i mean you you went to 50 i
was going to say 50 50.
you know 35 in investments that would be
okay too i'm just making it up here on
the spot
that'd be okay and there's nothing wrong
with putting all of it as a down payment
on the house no
but but there's just some sense about
this money
has been built slowly over time right as
an investment
um and so yeah about i'll be at a bad
one
so yeah that's what i would do with it
good question
good question man we appreciate you
joining us uh abby is on instagram
anthony i'm a 16 year old and i recently
quit my job due to working nights alone
oh smart i have the opportunity to get
right back into the workforce but i can
also spend my time working on my studies
for an upcoming test
this test can determine scholarships and
college acceptance
which should i choose clearly
i want you focusing on your tests uh
while we was walking out during the
break day we saw one of
one of our good friends and she
literally worked every single day
looking up grants looking up
scholarships preparing for the s.a.t
preparing for the act and she when she
raised a half a million dollars
dave um so that came back to like 500 an
hour she was making
and so i believe if you can take some
time to really focus on preparing for
the test
getting the sat cover getting the act
covered and getting some grants and
scholarships on the side
to get more grants and scholarships that
is a job you know as long as you can do
it well now
if you can do that and get a little
part-time job on the weekends
i like that even better but nothing
should stop you from focusing on your
studies
yeah yeah get your grades up and then
use the fact that you've got high grades
not for
possible yes college acceptance but for
probable
yes and not for possible scholarships
but put the us on grind like
like our friend did there absolutely
with it to go get the scholarships
make it your job that is your job yep
and
it's worth more than you know being a
whopper flopper
if my kids i'm gonna say this no and i
don't even marry but
that will be my kids job and if they
don't uh raise enough money and cash in
uh they're fired oh
that'll work all right thanks to james
childs our producer kelly daniel our
associate producer
and phone screener that's anthony o'neil
i'm dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
daveramsey.com show and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell your story
you